hello and welcome to this video playing
pups icon from the Netherlands right yes
so he goes with the night f3 declined
and therefore was one of the better
lines for white in this line and I think
it's roughly equal championship d2s not
really considered to be the only move
here I know it looks a bit strange to
check and play before but the bishop on
the two is Miss place and the other most
are not good so Queen see to an hour and
Andy for this one why does a normally
going for a little bit surprised okay
and he takes a bit him maybe it's new to
this this line I mean ok this is this is
a possibility of course yeah what can
also feel keto it's not a not a bad
option mmm interesting I could no no not
probably not playing Mikey Forrester
from this stupid idea so let's go here
does i really want to give me the bishop
here probably not he will go back and
then claim that age six was weakening my
position oh you never know ok
so yeah lucky normally goes five next
smooth or e6 I usually just go if I've
never quite sure what the c6 business
but maybe maybe I can play six and then
double on the e-file like group is seven
rookie aid kind of put pressure on you
for kind of an interesting that's
interesting let be three so this would
be so what he's saying is if i take he
is taking with you porn not a big deal
okay
so I need to activate here a little bit
at least when the position is is
comfortable for black but the bishop
won't be 7s is not doing anything and
it's not not that easy it takes it would
have to take with the night yeah or this
one maybe I don't know if it's a big
difference
he wants to Alton well he wants to
ultimately move the be protector be porn
here if I go look I sorry bishop c82 f5
this is certainly an idea i wonder if i
should worry about g4 probably not one
thing is that a four is unprotected now
so it's something that I have potential
temple moves like Bishop to d7 or queen
to the seven so that again a little bit
of time on that porn maybe
okay takes Bishop f5 and my lord winning
a barn or I'm oh I'm damn almost winning
this pawn I should a five you can take
age 6 I can maybe do this I wonder if we
could have pinned it I mean here I
should gain the e-file that was Queen to
e7 quit d7 as a double attack but he's
got 23 right let's keep the the pressure
on b3 maybe incoming
now I can know this is that a good idea
to play the small yeah I guess so the
base he almost has to check it the
bishop h6 rookie one should be good for
me at least I think it is
k
this is hanging here so if i take it
take be to whenever I should keep the
Queen's on with Queenie for here time I
think I want to keep the Queen's Own
remember McQueen only four is covering
be one so it's already made as I escort
let's say to the corn and it is six
maybe I should have traded Queens hello
I'm probably making life difficult him
like it is six and then I don't know
yeah but I can't stop this video now be
true we actually has 27
this position with two queens is quite
crazy come on let's do it this is too
funny your dad's you don't get this so
often and I think it's just just crazy
crazy now that's natural of the best
continuation but it just to find a year
with the two queens or four queens I
mean in total i wants to trade that's
that's a kind of a spoiler spoiled sport
check check check check check your wife
morphin time eff yeah it doesn't matter
i'm winning after five it was not really
playing this move poor that was a funky
some funky situation there with the Four
Queens but I felt it's funny I probably
should just take the ending yeah I'm
sometimes irrational them anyway so
let's put them and elders his own and
this is a normal situation for this line
i think i'm quite happy here i'm not a
huge fan of the fianchetto i think it
doesn't really do that much on the
diagonal and on d3 it covers more
squares so calm I mean here I should be
somewhat more comfortable under the
engine confirms that a bishop a 6 or
strong yeah you cannot prevent night XD
5a briefly thought about it but didn't
really I mean I was too tempting to to
centralize it all looks good here here
here yeah he I could have taken a good
Bishop f5 but I thought he would somehow
get age 6 which is not very important i
think i can just take here I I kind of
saw this and this and who but it really
isn't isn't any problem the be porn
seems to just clean now merciless
computer
okay that was a big opportunity here I
mean black has the e-file so I'm better
but it's not super super clear cap so no
g5 is better yeah but this wins yeah I
should just actually I should just
probably trade hi I am I tikis got the
porn so that is that sets that sets you
but you are trading a stupid Queen takes
be two is better than mine but not much
so that does win be 3g5 is questionable
and now Quincy true ok and now king of a
TI just use the king yeah the white
queen is kind of stuck there so this is
a full/queen situation actually does win
but I have to go queen e to see to hear
cold-blooded yeah the first week he
doesn't do much this is the computer
line and then it wants to take that's
cool ok now I'm not cold-blooded enough
for that I was happy to get to this and
yeah ha ha ha yeah okay now I go to the
winning king and porn ending it was
crazy you don't have four queens I never
had four queens I think I'm tournament
game I don't remember I don't think so
ok guys thanks for watching